So this is the second lecture on hybrid
workflows. So we started learning about
this on Wednesday.
And um
from Wednesday's lecture, I didn't quite
finish talking about auto
differentiation. So I want to carry on
explaining auto diff and and finishing
that section before I before I move on.
Um
so I've got some recap here.
So what I tried to show you on Wednesday
or explain is that
the vast majority of our scientific
programs that we write, um they can be
very complicated programs, uh but they
can be simply thought of as just vector
functions.
Where the program takes in, you know,
many arguments usually, but these
arguments are often just vectors and
matrices and and scalars and other such
things.
Uh
and their outputs are similarly
probably some sort of scalar or or
vector or tensor or something like this.
And so mathematically, we can just write
this whole scientific program down as
just
a composition of vector functions. So we
take some vector X as input, apply it
lots of functions sequentially,
um
uh and then we get our vector out Y as
output.
And we call these
intermediate functions primitive
functions. So we we can even though we
have lots of kind of complicated matrix
solves and other things in this example
hybrid Navier-Stokes solver that we were
looking at.
Uh we can
pull those down to their very primitive
operations. So they they usually things
like multiplications, divisions, uh
trigonometric transforms, etc.
So N here is usually a very very large
number.
And so what I told you on Wednesday is
that auto differentiation is this super
powerful tool that has been developed
through our deep learning libraries
uh
that allows us to efficiently compute
these two these two quantities. So, in
in particular, the vector Jacobian
product,
uh which is exactly this quantity here,
and then uh the Jacobian vector product.
And what I really tried to tell you is
that whilst we developed AutoDiff
primarily for training neural networks,
what's amazing about it and what's makes
it so powerful in scientific machine
learning is we can also use AutoDiff to
differentiate through these complicated
scientific programs to start learning
components in these programs.
Okay.
So, yeah, just as an example, this is a
pseudo code for learning a hybrid
Navier-Stokes solver. So, this is a
traditional numerical solver for solving
the for for carrying out fluid
simulation.
But inside the solver, we have a neural
network here that's applying some
learned correction. And
to train that neural network, we just
use AutoGrad to get the gradients of
some loss function with respect to the
the uh parameters of the network. And we
just treat the parameters of the network
as like it additional inputs to this
scientific program.
Um so, what is this torch.autograd.grad
doing behind the scenes? Well, what's it
what it's doing is computing this vector
Jacobian product.
So, in this case,
uh dL by dθ here is is not a full
Jacobian matrix because L is just a
scalar. It's a scalar value. So, uh the
vector Jacobian product of this quantity
is just a single number times by that uh
that uh single vector there.
Okay.
So, then I talked about how we compute
these vector Jacobian products, how
AutoDiff actually works, the machinery
behind it. And uh the way that we get
this uh vector Jacobian product is just
to decompose the Jacobian down to uh the
using the chain rule,
so that we can get the Jacobians of all
of these intermediate primitive
operations.
Um
and then the the actual algorithm works
like this. It's very simple. You just
start with a vector and then you go from
uh left to right here in so-called
reverse mode differentiation.
Uh
applying many many vector Jacobian
products. And these now are vector
Jacobian products that are of these
primitive operations.
So, to write like an auto
differentiation package or library, all
you need to do is first define all of
these primitive operations before we
would pass up these operations.
And then we need to define how we can
apply the vector Jacobian product to uh
you know, iteratively compute the the
the chain rule as we go through and we
back propagate through the through the
uh computation.
The other kind of cool trick that I
talked to talked to you about was that
uh we don't need to usually
fully populate or explicitly compute
these Jacobians.
Usually the primitive operations are
very simple and their Jacobians are
sparse and we can take that into account
to design an efficient auto diff uh
solver.
Okay, is that Who's with me? Who
understands that? Yeah. Great.
Good.
So, this is where I got to. I was
describing how we actually do auto diff
in practice. So, auto diff frameworks
like PyTorch, TensorFlow, and JAX, they
they work like this.
Um
when we're For example, let's talk think
about differentiating or back
propagating through a neural network
layer here or two layers.
So, the first thing you do is when you
when you when you define this in PyTorch
uh or TensorFlow,
what uh and you you run this function
forwards, what it does is it computes a
directed graph of these uh operations.
So, it You can You can think of this
function is just a a directed graph
where all of these intermediate
elements, you know, have lines depending
on which previous uh vectors or tensors
uh computed them.
Um
And then like I said, these packages for
each of these primitive operations that
we're applying,
they define the efficient versions of
the vector Jacobian and Jacobian vector
product of those primitive operations.
And then depending on whether you're
doing um
computing the vector Jacobian products
or doing reverse mode auto diff, or if
you're computing the Jacobian vector
products when you're doing forward mode
auto diff,
you uh either way you do message passing
through this graph to just iteratively
compute this uh
vector Jacobian products of the entire
function.
So this is how it would look for reverse
mode. You'd start with some incoming
vector here.
Um and remember we're going from left to
right, so carrying out our reverse, and
so we just do some message passing. So
then we uh
uh multiply that that vector with the dy
by db and dy by dw
um w2.
And then just keep going backwards
through the graph until we find finally
end up with the gradient with of the
output with respect to the first
weights, for example.
Um this is forward mode, so exactly the
same, we're just going a forward pass
through the network instead.
So we start with some incoming vector
again, and then it should be very
obvious what we do. We just
when we do a computation, we just also
do the vector Jacobian product of that
computation as well, so we we update
these vectors as we go through the
forward pass of the of the computation.
Just like this.
So
um
I think it's very interesting to to
discuss this question about the memory
requirements of auto diff.
So I've got a question here. So can
anyone answer this? Like how does the
required memory, so if you think about
you know, the the arrays that we have to
store in memory uh, to do the forward
pass and also the back prop pass.
How does this memory scale with the
depth of the forward computation?
The the reverse mode and for the forward
mode and and and how does that is it is
it is it different?
Does anyone know?
You can also reply in the chat if you uh
if you have no idea.
Okay, so uh
let me show you these animations again.
Um
when we when we're computing uh back
prop when we're doing back prop
uh
to be able to compute for example uh
this this quantity here. So
uh dy by dh
uh
or uh dy by dw, we need to know what the
value of y is with y is before. That's
part of the kind of Jacobian.
Um
similarly when we go backwards through
the graph, we need to have stored the
value of h and the value of b and w1 to
be able to go backwards through the
graph.
So to do reverse mode auto diff
we need we need to have computed and
stored all the inter intermediate
computations of the graph as before we
start doing back prop.
Does that make sense to everyone?
Yeah?
So how does the memory scale with with
depth in that case?
Yeah. It's linear, right? Yeah. So the
the amount of memory required it depends
on the the depth of the forward
computation. So it's it's linearly
dependent.
So now if I show you the the graph for
forward mode, can anyone tell me how the
memory is different? So now we're going
forwards. We start with a vector.
We do the first kind of set of primitive
operations. We update the vector
Jacobian product and then we go through.
So, how So, how is how much memory do we
need in this situation?
Yeah. Yeah, great.
So, we we don't need to store these
intermediate activations cuz we're we're
already updating the product as we go
along.
So,
it's really interesting, not always
appreciated, is that
uh when we do backprop, we have to store
our intermediate computations, and that
scales linearly with it.
When we do forward mode, we get memory
independent uh autodiff. So,
so, it's very very interesting
difference uh and can be used quite
effectively, especially when we have
really long uh kind of computational uh
functions. We can maybe you sometimes
forward mode is better than reverse
mode, depending on the gradients that
you want.
Um okay.
So, yeah, I mean, I've explained in
detail now what autodiff is. The uh in
practice, you don't have to worry about
this stuff, right?
So, we can just
just hand this over to PyTorch or
TensorFlow, and this is what these
deep learning libraries are so amazing
at is just
doing all this stuff behind the scenes.
And And what this will just equate to in
PyTorch is just calling, for example,
loss.backward, and it does uh updates
the gradients for us.
If you actually look at the kind of
documentation of PyTorch
and read it uh for torch.autograd.grad,
you can see it's doing exactly what
we've been talking about. So,
um
it computes the vector Jacobian product
here
uh of the output with respect to the
input.
And uh this uh grad outputs here is just
the vector that we're we're doing in
that computation. So,
so, hopefully, you should fully
understand how this kind of uh
uh
function is is working now.
So, yeah, I mean, there are also a
couple of other misconceptions about
what autograd is
or is not in fact. So, yeah, you should
appreciate this by now that
autograd is definitely not symbolic
differentiation. It also isn't doing
finite differences. We're getting exact
gradients when we're when we're running
autograd.
So, it simply is a way of efficiently
computing exact gradients. So, so make
sure you're aware of the difference of
these methods.
Yeah.
It's just the vector that you apply. So,
when you're doing this vector Jacobian
products, it's the it's this incoming
message.
So,
remember, so let me go all the way back
to the first slide.
So, in general, we have some vector
function.
And then we autograd gets the vector
Jacobian product.
So, this could give you a vector vector
as output. Wait, in fact, it will give
you a vector as output.
Um
But, when we typically what we're doing
is we want the
gradient of the loss with respect to the
theta. So, this you can think of this as
a Jacobian.
But, it's a it's a just it's just one
row because the loss is a scalar value,
right?
So, what's the vector Jacobian product
of a single row? It's just a scalar
times by that row.
And we always choose that scalar to be
one when we call loss.backwards
in PyTorch. So, typically we don't even
specify it because it's just assumed
that it's one.
But, if if you were trying to
differentiate if here the output is not
a scalar,
but it's actually a vector,
then you need to define like an actual
vector that you're going to compute the
vector Jacobian product with.
Um
So, yeah, usually usually we don't
really
Yeah, see here, it's just one. When
we're doing a loss.backwards.
Okay.
Any other questions before we move on?
So, yeah, then I So, I was introducing
hybrid approaches last lecture. So, I
said throughout the course so far we've
mostly concentrated on
replacing our scientific workflows with
a with a neural network and
that neural network
has some interesting understanding of
sci- of scientific understanding either
through the loss function or through the
architecture.
But, now we're really focusing on these
hybrid approaches where we're keeping
our traditional algorithms and instead
we're putting learnable components quite
very tightly into those into those
algorithms.
And I showed you last lecture how we can
use auto diff to train those
learnable components end-to-end.
Um and so, why are we doing this? Why
are hybrid approaches useful? Well, as I
was talking about
you know, deep neural networks certainly
have their advantages, but they also
have some big disadvantages.
For example, they need a lot of training
data, they're hard to optimize, etc.
So, this is the key kind of idea of
these hybrid approaches is why don't we
directly incorporate a neural network or
some learnable component into our
algorithms just to either accelerate the
workflow or to kind of learn the parts
of the algorithm that we don't
understand or maybe
um
uh allow us to learn kind of incomplete
physics that we haven't put into the
into the program.
Um I also showed you this hybrid
Navier-Stokes solver. So, we So, we uh
we looked at
simulating fluids
and we realized that
uh numerical traditional numerical
algorithms have a problem with
discretization error.
Or said differently, the accuracy or the
accuracy of these simulations strongly
depends on the number of mesh cells that
you that you use.
Um and so with a small number of mesh
cells cells we get a really inaccurate
kind of simulation.
So we looked into this this hybrid
approach here where we uh took the low
fidelity solver, but we added a
learnable component to it uh to try and
improve its accuracy.
Um what that learnable component did is
it just we just put a neural network
um into the inner loop of the hybrid
solver.
Um the network took the each low
fidelity step and tried to learn a
correction to make it uh look more like
the uh
um
corresponding high fidelity step.
Um
and so yeah, this is the pseudo code for
the hybrid solver and it has the neural
network in the middle of the code. And
we're using autograd to differentiate
through this whole algorithm end-to-end
with a loss function that just matches
the final outputs of the hybrid solver
with some ground truth high fidelity
simulation.
Um
and so yeah, this is this is the key
idea uh of hybrid techniques. We also
call this differentiable physics uh
using autodeff to differentiate and
learn physical algorithms.
Hopefully that kind of key idea you
fully understand and appreciate now.
Okay.
So how do we do this in practice? Uh
or like how how would you generalize
this to any kind of scientific program
that you want to learn?
It's super simple and this is advice
that I give many people uh that want to
try and try hybrid approaches out
themselves.
There's like literally four steps that
you have to take uh
So step one is just to take your
traditional scientific algorithm
and rewrite it into an auto
differentiation framework.
This is usually the hardest step. This
can take a long time depending on your
traditional code so
if you think about uh uh
high performance code a lot of it is
written in Fortran or uh like other C++
for example.
So this can take a lot of effort but but
once you've done it, you get some big
gains.
So for example PyTorch or JAX, we'll
we'll be talking about JAX. I've got an
introduction in the
lecture coming up.
So then step two is is to then
open up this algorithm and and allow it
to be more flexible. What I mean by that
is putting learnable components
somewhere in that algorithm.
So for example like learning correction
of a discretized numerical solver or it
could be even simpler. It could just be
learning like a single scalar value,
maybe a time stepping value or something
like this.
Step three, just grab some training data
of what you expect the outputs of that
algorithm to be.
This is where your real world data comes
into practice. We need to learn these
algorithms from some sort of data.
And
then step four, just train your
algorithm with auto diff. Just compute a
loss function of the outputs and just
let auto diff get your gradients for
you.
And then added bonus,
all of these deep learning libraries are
designed for doing parallel matrix
operations
and they run much better on the GPU and
and
the bonus is that once you've rewritten
your traditional workflow, it will also
run on the GPU and depending on the type
of computation that it carries out, it
may well be
an order of magnitude faster than a CPU
implementation or even more sometimes.
Okay.
So yeah, hybrid approaches insert
learnable components inside traditional
algorithms and auto diff is really the
key enabler for not only hybrid
approaches but all the other sign up
methods that we've talked about.
Okay, so I'm going to move on to now the
second part of hybrid workflows Um, and
in this part is composed of two things.
So,
first I'm going to do some live coding
with you just to show you how easy it is
to to write a scientific program in
PyTorch and then differentiate through
it and learn something about the the
scientific process.
And then, um, I have one other example
of a hybrid workflow, which is more
complex, uh, really showing you kind of
the limits of what you can do with
hybrid hybrid, uh, modeling.
Um, this workflow is for solving inverse
problems. So, instead of carrying out
forward simulation, we're going to try
and learn something about some
underlying parameters of the system.
Um, so I don't know if I'll get to this
in this lecture, but we'll, uh, carry on
next lecture if if we if we don't make
it.
So, yeah, we're going to be able to
hopefully by the end of this, uh, part,
you should be able to
experiment with hybrid approaches
yourself in PyTorch, uh, by using the
code.
And, uh, understand kind of,
uh, advanced hybrid methods.
Okay, so what I'm going to do
is, uh, switch.
So, if I
share my Chrome tab.
So, I just want to check, uh,
people in the Zoom, can you see my
Chrome my Jupyter notebook?
Okay, good.
And you can see it. Okay, good.
Okay, so what we're going to do is, uh,
investigate this this problem. So, who
who has seen, uh, this this problem
before? It's called the book Yeah, all
right, a lot of pretty much everyone.
Okay, so I guess it's been, uh, on the
internet a lot. Uh, quite a good
interactive demo to to teach people
with.
So, this is just the uh, a really
interesting problem, which is to say,
um, if a ball is going to travel from
one point to another by rolling down a
slope,
what should be the shape of the slope
such that the ball arrives at the
fastest possible time to this to the
second location?
And uh it's not actually intuitively
obvious, in my opinion, uh what line
should what line it should take, like a
linear line or a very steep line or or
something in the middle.
And so
uh
kind of long story short, there's a
special curve called uh the
the brachistochrone.
The uh brachistochrone even. Uh
which uh is this this shape here that
gets the ball there the fastest.
Um so there's some really nice math that
you can uh use to kind of prove this or
to derive that that the shape of the
curve.
But what we can do here is we're going
to say, okay,
uh we don't we haven't got the equation
for that curve, but we just want to try
and learn it from just using uh
a neural network to approximate that
that uh line.
So yeah, here's the problem again.
What's the shape of the curve which a a
ball starting from rest and accelerated
by gravity will roll without friction
from one point to another in the least
amount of time?
So what we're going to do is we're going
to say, we don't know what this curve
is, which we're just going to call it Y
as a function of X in the in this 2D 2D
setting.
And we just let the initial location be
the origin and then the second location
be X2 to Y2.
And so yeah, our approach is going to be
we're going to try and learn what this
function is just with a neural network.
Uh so we're going to say the neural
network directly approximates this this
this line that the ball travels on.
So how do we train this network? How
would you train or how would you try to
learn such a network?
The answer's on the on
that one. Um so there but it's just
Yeah. thing you want to minimize.
Exactly, yeah. Right, so we're just
going to
we're going to minimize the thing we
want to minimize. So the end the final
thing is the is the time of the
simulation.
Uh but that's important, right? So we're
not um we're not going to minimize we're
not going to give the network examples
of the line.
We're going to minimize some other
quantity that we actually care about,
which is some quantity that is is
computed from that line.
So this is where the hybrid modeling
comes from. Is what we're going to do is
we're going to like given the line,
we're going to compute the time it takes
for the ball to roll on
along that line using a physics kind of
solver and then differentiate through
that solver to kind of learn the
network.
So you can kind of see how this hybrid
approach is being designed now.
Um
So um how do we compute this uh total
travel time for an arbitrary line? Well,
we just use, you know, distance equals
speed times time, but we need to do an
integral because the line is a is a uh
not a linear line. Um
You can I'm not going to go through this
in detail, but one way to derive uh this
travel time in terms of f of x is just
to use conservation of energy and
um plug that in and rearrange this
integral. And what you what you end up
with is the travel time
uh is this integral uh which depends on
the gradient of the line here and also
the line the line itself and also the
gravitational constant. So
So what we need to do is we need to be
able to uh evaluate this this integral
in PyTorch uh given the output of the
network
to be able to to be able to compute the
travel time and then then differentiate
through this whole thing to be able to
learn the weights of the of the network.
Any any questions on the kind of overall
approach before I talk about the code?
Does it make sense that what loss
function we're using?
Yeah.
And it makes sense that the loss
function is some sort of integral all
the gradient and the values of the of
the network.
Okay.
So, a couple of interesting things about
the loss. One is that we don't just need
the value of the of the line, we also
need the gradient. So, how how are we
going to compute that?
Auto diff. Yeah, so we're going to use
auto diff
twice, actually. We're going to use auto
diff to get the gradient of the line,
but we're also going to use auto diff to
get the gradient of the loss function.
So,
uh like we saw in physics-informed
neural networks, we can use auto diff in
a compositional way. We can apply it
many times, which is super powerful.
So, yeah, the exact solution, if you're
interested, you can follow this link
afterwards. Uh it's a cycloid. It's uh a
parametric parametric solution.
Um
and uh we're going to compare to that
when we when we plot the results. So,
Okay, so uh first we're just going to
uh import torch, and we're going to just
define a cycloid so we can compare that
to the exact solution.
And then, uh the first thing I want to
do is define this kind of flexible
function that that represents the line
the ball's going to travel along.
Um so, we're going to use a neural
network. Remember, I'm going to say
uh here,
the the line is just approximated
directly by the network.
So, the network should take as an input
the X coordinate and give me the value
of Y as the output, right? That's just
the the line that is that it's giving.
So, um what I have is just a simple
fully connected network.
Uh it has one input, the X value, and
one output for the Y value.
Um with a bunch of layers. Uh
And so, now in my forward call, I'm it's
just going to given the X value, it's
going to return return Y.
What I've also done here is give the
forward call uh the value of X2 and Y2.
So, this is the final point that the
network the the ball is going to end up
at.
This is just to normalize my inputs.
Remember, we have to make sure we have
nice nice normalized inputs for our
neural network. So, that's just going to
help me normalize X.
Now, I'm going to do something a little
more clever than just say Y equals the
neural network of X. I'm actually going
to use um a hard cons- Well, I'm going
to use a a residual model. So, like we
were talking about in hybrid methods, we
can if we know like if we have an
assumption about what the line should
look like, we don't have to learn the
whole thing. We can just learn the
residual part of the line.
So, what's a So, a good start and guess,
for example, if I don't know what this
line is, I can just say, "Okay, let's
just start with a linear a linear line,
right?" And we'll just have the network
learn a correction to that linear linear
line. Maybe maybe that's an easier
learning problem than learning the whole
the whole line.
So, we phrase our answers kind of if the
if the line is this, we're going to say
we're going to assume that the the line
is linear, and then we're going to have
the network just learn some residual
correction in a in a additive way.
So, it's actually very simple. So, first
we just compute what our linear line
would be
uh as a function Sorry, here. And uh the
linear line is just given the ball
starts at the origin, it's just uh you
know, if the gradient the gradient times
by X. Y equals MX plus C, you know.
Um
So, that's uh that's the that's the
linear part here.
And so, then we then we need to compute
the the residual part that the network's
going to learn. So, the correction to
the linear line.
So, then we just pass X through our our
neural network. So, this is self.
So, this going through each each layer.
So, the starting layer.
Uh
here.
And then
and then the hidden state
and then the final state.
Like this. So, these are just the layers
of the neural network that I'm passing
passing it through. I've made a mistake
there.
And then at the end we're just going to
add the linear model
to to the Y value like like this.
Um
So you can see how we apply this kind of
correction.
So we need to I'm just going to change
this doing a few other kind of tricks or
to make sure that it converges quickly.
The first is I'm going to make sure that
the input to the network is normalized.
So at the moment X is going to range
from 0 to 0 to X2
as I've defined the problem.
What range should we normally have our
inputs to the neural network?
Yeah.
0 to 1 or So I'm using a tan H here. So
what what range do you think I should
use?
So that I don't saturate the the tan H
function.
Anyone else? Yeah.
-1 to -1. Yeah, so So what I can do is
just
uh normalize it like this.
And now you can see when X is from 0 to
X2, then I've normalized it to -1 to 1.
Or uh I think I think it's right or is
it half that?
It's It's fine as long as it's the the
right order of magnitude.
Um
And then the final thing I'm going to do
is is this. So I'm going to times uh the
final output by
uh torch.tanH
X
and torch.
uh tanH X minus uh
X2.
And anyone guess why what that does? Why
why is that
a useful thing to do? Why does that make
any sense?
So I'm taking the
the uh
the the residual prediction of the
network and I'm timesing it by tanH X
and tanH X minus 2.
Why have I done Why have I done that?
Okay, so what this is doing is it's
asserting our
conditions of our of our problem, right?
So, we know that the ball has to pass
through zero zero and it has to end at
Y2 X2.
And we designed our linear line.
Remember we're saying
the line is the linear line plus the
neural network direction. We already
designed a linear line so that it
already goes through zero and
X2 Y2 just by using this
this equation for the linear line.
So, what value does the network need to
add at the at the starting point and the
end point?
Zero, yeah.
So, what does this what does this do at
X2 and and X X equals zero?
Yeah. Well, more precisely it it just
says
whatever the output of the network is at
XX
at X equals two this thing's going to be
zero and at X equals zero this is going
to be zero. So, it's just going to force
this linear this residual correction is
to be zero.
Yeah. Yeah, so yeah, good good spot.
Thanks, too.
So, let me just check this. I think I
think it's all good otherwise.
X minus X2
Yeah, I think it's what I've written up
here. So, I think we're good.
Okay, so
so we create that.
And now what we have to do is
train the network.
So, what what I've got set up here is a
simple PyTorch training loop just like
you've seen before. So, you know,
create creating the model here. We've
got
eight
hidden eight hidden states and and two
layers. So, it's a very small neural
network.
We're creating an Adam optimizer to
train the network. So, this is all
standard stuff.
Um
So, all we need to do now is to compute
the travel time because remember we're
going to minimize the travel time with
respect to the network's weights to try
and learn this learn this curve.
So, we have to come up with a way to
compute this integral.
So, how do we evaluate an integral?
Uh
Well, how how would we do this
numerically? Anyone Anyone have any
ideas?
Yeah.
Quadrature? Yeah. Yeah, so we we need to
discretize this so we can compute it.
So, we can use quadrature. What I'm
going to use is the trapezium rule, so
like a even simpler simpler method for
now, but yeah, for sure you could use
some something better.
Um
So,
uh
So, what I've got here is um we're going
to sample X along the whole range um so
we can compute that integral. We need to
sample uh we have we need to have many
values of X.
So, we're just going to do a uh
a linear linear sampling of X.
And then we're going to compute the
model's output, so this is the
prediction of the of the full line.
And what we need to do here is compute
the travel time, so
the first thing I need is uh dy by dx,
which is this torch.autograd
.autograd
so Y and X, and then we need the vector
of the Jacobian product, so
uh we're just going to do 1 / X.
And uh I have to get the the zero at the
output of that of that alpha there.
So, this is where we're using autograd
to get the dy by dx in in the uh in the
time uh time value
in the integral.
So, once we've got this, then we just
need to compute the
uh the function that we're integrating,
so I'm just going to write this square
root.
So, uh we're going to say f equals
torch.square root.
And then I think it's 1 + dy by dx
squared.
I forgot 2 * g * y.
Like this. 1 + 3.
1 + that squared dy dy. Okay.
And then we're going to use uh
the trapezium rule to integrate or
basically sum the values of x together.
Yeah, cool.
Yeah.
It may well be. Yeah, if you can if you
can write that analytically then yeah,
pure is much better.
Uh but otherwise quadrature or Monte
Carlo sampling or something there's
there's other ways to evaluate it. Um
Okay, so we're going to use the
trapezium rule. So, torch has uh this
function called torch.trapezoid. So, it
makes it super easy.
So, it just computes the trapezium rule.
So, it's going to approximate that
integral with these with these uh
points.
So, I just need to do
uh
T. So, this is the total travel time is
torch.trapezoid
uh
and we need to give it uh
function values and and then the x
values like that like this and then we
say we're going to sum across the zeroth
dimension. So,
I'm I'm I think this is pretty much it.
The the rest is just to call torch uh
t.backward. This is, you know, diff uh
doing backprop to get the gradients of
the network.
Um and we take an optimizer step and we
do that in a for loop and and then we're
just going to plot the the curves as it
as it learns.
There is one thing that I've missed
which is
uh we need to create create the graph
with.
So, that uh we can differentiate through
that uh gradient graph as well.
So, let's see if it runs.
I think it's going okay. Yeah, okay. So,
what I've got here is uh two plots. So,
one is the
prediction of the full
full line. So, this is the linear model
plus the neural network correction.
Uh and so, this is very interesting. So,
this is before we've done any training
steps. So, what you can see already is
it looks like a linear model. So, this
is why we have this linear model as a
starting guess.
It's got a little bump here, so maybe
the network's done a little correction
from its random initialization.
Also, it passes through those two
points. So, we've done these higher
boundary constraints, which is really
nice. So, whatever the network learns,
it's always going to pass through the
two points.
Then, the orange curve is the
brachistochrone. So, this is the cycloid
solution. And then, you can also plot
the the velocity of the ball as it's as
it's traveling. It's just interesting to
look at it.
So, yeah, as we're as we're
optimizing the network, we're we're
reducing the travel time that it takes.
This is the thing that we're optimizing.
And we just start to converge closer and
closer onto this exact solution.
So,
that's it. That's that's an example of
using a neural network inside of a
physics workflow, you know, a workflow
to compute travel times, and
differentiating through the whole
workflow to to learn that component of
the of the program.
Yeah.
Uh yeah, I think that would be that's
something you should we should test, I
think. Probably depends on the
Lagrangian, but what might be
interesting is if you wrote a general
purpose code that could take any
Lagrangian as input.
Um there's an aside, there's these
things called Hamiltonian neural
networks, which try to learn
Hamiltonians. This is a whole different
subject, but people are trying to learn
at this sort of higher level of
abstraction as well. And that gets
really interesting as far as the physics
is concerned.
Any other Any other questions?
Okay.
So we've got 5 minutes left. So I'm
going to
I'm going to start the next section, but
we'll finish it on Wednesday next week.
Um so what we're going to do is what I'm
going to do is describe one final hybrid
approach,
probably the most advanced hybrid
approach that I'm going to tell you
about.
And we're going to use we're going to
design an algorithm a hybrid algorithm
to solve this problem. So this is
computed tomography.
Um hands up who's seen this before
or knows of this kind of general
problem.
Okay.
So
this is an inverse problem.
And
the
the goal is well, computed tomography
is used by
is is used in medical diagnosis like
it's used probably everyone's had a
x-ray scan in their lives at some point.
And what we see when we when we when
they give us a scan is these are these
images.
Um but that's not actually what the
instrument is recording when when you
have the x-ray scan.
What the instrument actually records are
these things called sinograms, which are
these really interesting like wavy kind
of
images that they they record.
And the the
So what what is actually happening in in
an x-ray or a computed tomography scan?
What you have is some media. So for
example, someone's head or some other
part of your body. And you have an x-ray
source, which you can think of just as a
point source.
And these x-rays just travel through
straight lines of this media and end up
being detected at some screen here.
And what we actually detect is the
intensity of the of the x-ray at the
screen. So after it's propagated through
the whole media.
And so what this sinogram is showing is
just the intensity
uh
this axis here.
And the other thing that we do in the
experiment is we we rotate the media
around and we record, uh, you know, the
the intensity as a function of rotation.
So, that's the other dimension of this
image here is the angle of rotation.
So, this is the little graphic showing,
you know, if you if you recorded the
intensity through this media, this is
what you'd get.
So, the intensity that we record is, uh,
varies and it just depends on the
absorption of the of the media itself.
So, you can think of of, uh, each part
of the brain here is absorbing the the
X-rays differently.
And this is what we eventually want to
end up with is this image of the
absorption. So, this absorption is a
function of X and Y.
We can write this mathematically, uh,
using our understanding of the physics.
Uh, we know that actually the intensity
is just a simple integration, a line
integration, over the line the X-rays
traveled and and the absorption, uh,
function itself, or the absorption
image.
So, does this make sense kind of the
problem and the basis that we have and
how we want the how we want to solve it?
We want to go from this this observed
data to our actual underlying image.
Okay, good.
And, uh, so I'll
Yeah, so here here's the inverse problem
is, uh, I've just described the forward
problem, which is just integrating the
the image across all these lines
and angles.
But, the inverse problem is like given
some, uh, observed sinogram, can we get
back to the image? And and that's not
always, uh, easy. In fact, it's very
hard quite a lot of the time.
And so, yeah, I talked about this kind
of super high-level kind of, uh,
framework in the first lecture where I
said, you know, many problems can be
boiled down to this where we where we
have some, uh, physical system which has
some input conditions. We have some
forward model of that system and then we
get some um, um resulting properties B.
So, the inverse problem is given B to
decide what A is or figure out what A A
is.
Um
And so, I'm going to tell you how we do
this traditionally and then we'll talk
about the hybrid approach next next
lecture, so.
Traditionally, we often frame these
inverse problems in general as as an
optimization problem. It's fundamentally
as a search problem.
You know, given B, we want to find a
possible value of A that produce B.
So, we can write it as an optimization
problem. It's just a minimization of B
uh
or a minimization where we try to, you
know,
guess what A is, carry out some forward
simulation of the system, and try and
match it to the to the observational
data.
So, uh this is an objective function or
a loss function and we can we can learn
A just like we train neural networks by
using gradient descent. So, we can
get the gradient of this loss function
with respect to A and then do a gradient
descent step to the to learn A.
Um so, what this requires is that our
forward model, the thing that So, say if
I give you an image
and
um you have an algorithm that produces
the the signogram, carries out that this
forward simulation of the X-ray,
uh
that needs to be differentiable.
So, that we can differentiate through F
to to get gradients of the loss function
with respect to A.
So, we're going to be using auto diff to
differentiate through our forward solver
just like we've done
uh just like I've been describing uh
before.
You follow uh Who's with me so far?
Okay.
Good.
So, let me just draw it out as like a
diagram, so uh
this is the same thing, gradient descent
just drawn as a diagram. So, we have to
start with some initial guess of what
the of the image is.
Then we carry out forward modeling using
you know, simple forward forward
simulation.
And then we have some real data here
that we observe from our experiment you
know, after I've had my x-ray, this is
the data we actually receive.
Then we create our loss function, we
match our predicted image to the to the
real data, then we get the gradients of
the loss function with respect to the
image and then we update the update the
image.
We do that many hundreds, maybe
thousands of times and we end up with
some final final model.
Um
So I think I'll stop there
and we'll talk about how we would
improve this workflow and learn
something about it in the in the next
lecture.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, so
I maybe this label is a bit redundant.
It's just F. It's just the output of the
simulation.
So yeah, it's
you could just have this this box here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you everyone. So I'll see you see
you on on Wednesday next week.
Okay, I think we'll get started.
Um
So we're going to carry on this lecture
talking about this computed tomography
example which we started talking about
the end of last lecture.
And what I'm going to explain to you is
a kind of hybrid scientific machine
learning workflow that's going to be
able to help us solve this inverse
problem.
Um
So
let me just recap what the problem is
of computer tomography. So this is just
basically taking x-ray images of our
bodies. So everyone's had a kind of
x-ray scan before I imagine.
Um
And what we see after we have the test
is an image of whatever part of what of
the body we've scanned.
But what we actually record in the
sensor is is not the image, we record
this so-called sinogram which is
the measurement of the intensity of the
x-ray
after it's gone through the media and
once it's hit a screen.
Um
and we know from physics that this is
just the integration of the
intensities a function of X and Y, so
remember each part of the media has a
different
absorption coefficient.
So, we just we just integrate that
absorption coefficient in a line
integral to get the intensity at the
screen.
And then
what also happens in the experiment is
the the media rotates or or the actually
the x-ray source rotates around the
media.
And so that's that gives us this extra
dimension in the in the image, which is
the the rotation angle.
So, it gives you this kind of these
sinograms and and so the the inverse
problem here is to take
observations of the sinogram here and
try and invert back for the for the
image or the absorption profile as a
function of space.
Everyone clear on on the problem and and
the physics behind it?
Great.
Okay.
So, yeah, this is the inverse problem to
take this observed sinogram and go back
to the to the image.
And if you look at the kind of images
that we actually produce, depending on
the number of observations we have, so
this is you know, the number of
detectors and the number of rotation
angles that we choose,
these images
can be very noisy. So, we can't it's
actually quite difficult to invert for
the for the underlying image.
Can anyone give me a reason why this
image doesn't look exactly like the kind
of perfect image?
What would be a reason why we we don't
reconstruct the a perfect image?
Yeah, it's
Yeah.
So, you're right. we just had one
observation of the intensity it's like a
summation and we're losing information
if the if the absorption through that
line.
But what we do have is multiple
observations.
So actually it turns out if you have
enough kind of angles and enough
detectors and enough lines to go through
the media
then you can invert for the underlying
image and actually the quality of the
result depends on the number of kind of
observations and the number of angles
that we pass through through the media.
So we can frame this as a as an
optimization problem or more
fundamentally it's a search problem. We
want to find you know the image
that if we simulate the observed sign up
ground so if we pass x-rays through that
image and and produce what we think is a
sign up ground it should match what our
real world observational data is once
we've done the scan.
So typically we'll frame it as an
optimization problem where we have some
loss function which can in the simplest
case just be the difference between the
observed data and the the simulation of
the observed data.
And then if this kind of forward model
is differentiable then we can just do
gradient descent to to update the image.
And so I showed you this kind of picture
or this is just a picture of what I just
showed in the last slide.
So what you do normally is you start
with some guess of what the the image is
usually some smooth or even constant
constant guess.
You take in your real world data here.
You do forward modeling of the image to
to guess what the forward data looks
like. This is what the synthetic data is
here.
And then we compute the loss function
and then we can compute gradients of the
loss with respect to the to the image
and we do a gradient descent.
Who's with me so far?
Okay.
So as as I was trying to point out, this
is actually quite a difficult problem
depending on kind of the number of
observations that we have, the number of
the number of lines here, and the number
of angles that we scan
over the media.
Um, and so this is fundamentally and
this is a general property of inverse
problems. This is what what makes it
really hard to solve inverse problems
is that there's in general usually not
enough information in our observed
uh uh signogram uh to be able to
uniquely reconstruct the image.
So, another way of saying that is this
is like a one-to-many map. There's uh
you know, many possible solutions that
could produce this observational data.
What makes this also hard is we often
have noise in real-world settings. So,
there'll be noise from the detector, and
this just increases the kind of
ill-posedness of the of the inverse
problem.
Um
So, what we you need to do to solve to
solve these in general, if we have a
search task, we have to have some prior
understanding of what the solution might
be. So, what does a like typical image
look like, for example?
And we have to the the main way to solve
inverse problems effectively is to try
and incorporate that kind of prior
understanding into our search algorithm
to help us kind of find the right image.
And so, one way you can do this, there
are many ways in inverse problems, but
one way is to add an extra term into the
loss function.
And we call this a regularization term.
So, think back to our introduction to
deep learning. We also regularize deep
neural networks to find good networks
that fit data. We're doing exactly the
same concept here, but for inverse
problems. So,
So, what this regularizer will say is it
will take it will take an image, your
current guess of what the image is, and
it will kind of give you a a heuristic
that says, "Yeah, this is a good image."
Or maybe this isn't a good image. So,
this uh this regularizer might be higher
for a for a for a poor image and and
lower for a good image.
So, one that we use very traditionally
is called total variation, and this just
says that
uh you know, that the
gradient of the image should be close to
zero.
So what do you think that does? What
types of images does does that prefer?
Anyone guess why we would use like a
why we would prefer gradients to be zero
of the image?
Yes, please.
Smooth, yes. Smoothness constraint,
yeah.
So I mean, this image is quite noisy. So
if you think about the gradient, the
spatial gradients of this image is going
to be that's going to be quite high or
lots of spurious values.
If I looked at the the real image
here, you can see it's actually
smoother.
So there are some step changes where the
the spatial gradients are high, but in
the majority of the image the spatial
gradients are quite quite low.
So this is kind of a good good heuristic
to to add and trying to try to guide our
our search towards a good image.
Now the other issue with inverse
problems is
F here. So when when we compute this
loss function,
we need to take our image and do a
simulation of what we think the the
observed signogram is.
And in general, this forward simulation
can be very computationally expensive.
So you know, if we're doing
problems where we have to do like a
finite difference simulation or finite
element simulation,
this can be just expensive to do one
forward simulation, but then when we're
doing gradient descent on this loss, we
actually have to run the simulation
forwards maybe
1,000 times, 10,000 times and and this
makes the inverse problem really really
computationally expensive to solve.
Okay, so
what I tried to give you there was just
an understanding of the kind of
challenges of of existing way to solve
inverse problems, which is using
gradient descent.
Um so, what I want you to do is
have a quick discussion with your
neighbor about ways that you might be
able to improve this workflow
by incorporating kind of a learnable
element or maybe a a neural network
inside of this workflow somewhere.
So, remember this is um we're we're
talking about hybrid techniques. This is
what we've been talking about for the
last few lectures.
And the goal would be to try and insert
some learnable component or neural
network like in one of these boxes or
some somehow into this into this
workflow.
So, either try and speed up the workflow
or to try and improve kind of the
accuracy of the of the final the final
image.
So, just have a quick discussion with
your neighbor, maybe just for a minute
or so, and then I'll ask you uh what
ideas you have.
The people on Zoom, please feel free to
um write something in the chat, and then
I can mention it.
Okay, so that was a a quick discussion.
Can anyone raise a hand and
give me an idea where you might think
about
putting a a neural network or some
learnable component into this into this
workflow.
Yeah, please.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, great idea.
So, as I explained, this forward
modeling here is very expensive to run
if it's like a if we have to run like
finite difference simulation or
something like this.
So, we can train like a surrogate model,
just a neural network that approximates
that forward model. Maybe it takes in
the the image and gives guess of what
the sinogram is. And that might be
thousands of times faster, so yeah, good
idea.
Any Anyone else? There are many answers,
by the way.
Yeah, please.
Yeah. Okay.
Very interesting. Okay.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
I see. Yeah.
So, you would So, you would have an a
neural network in here somewhere?
That would take
What would it What would it What would
it take as its input?
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So, maybe it learns like a better
direction
in this
Yeah.
Very good. Yep. Okay. Anyone else?
There are many other options as well.
Okay. So, two two very good ideas.
Um
you managed to guess exactly what I'm
going to going to show you. So, so what
So, what Well done.
Um
this is exactly what we're going to try
and do is we're going to have
a a neural network here
um which tries to take a better
direction than gradient descent.
So,
why is this a good idea? Well, we're
just kind of trusting that if you
imagine our loss landscape, uh
you know, in general loss landscapes are
very non-linear but and non-convex,
which means they have lots of local
minima and are very hard to navigate and
also very high-dimensional spaces to
navigate.
So, just following the gradient uh
direction
is not by any means guaranteed to get us
to the kind of global minimum or even a
local minimum of the of the problem.
Um so, what we're going to try and do is
we're going to try and search that space
better
by trying to learn a better step to take
in that loss landscape than just to
follow the gradient direction.
Does that make sense the general
concept? I'm going to go into this in
much more detail, but
Good.
So, what is this network going to do?
So, it's going to take in as as you were
suggesting, it's going to take in
perhaps the gradient of the loss with
respect to the weights. So, you know,
the the the step that gradient descent
would take if we just do gradient
descent.
Um
and then the image maybe or maybe just
everything else we have inside this for
loop available to us. So, we have the
current image, we'll have the original
observational data, we may even have
some values of some regularization terms
that might tell us how good that image
is like a guess about how good the image
is.
Uh
and so, we just put this neural network
into this inner loop of the of the
hybrid solver.
So, I've got some pseudo code here. So,
what what I'm writing in the pseudo code
is just gradient descent. Um
and I've written it out as a for loop as
well. So, again, this is just that
diagram that I I showed before.
And this is the kind of standard
gradient descent algorithm. So, again,
we start with initial guess, we do this
for loop where we compute gradients,
then we take gradient descent steps. Not
nothing new.
So, what I'm going to write in the
right-hand side here is the the hybrid
version where we're going to learn this
gradient descent step.
So, this looks like looks like this.
And in the pseudo code, I've just
highlighted here just the changes to the
pseudo code. So, you can see this is
super simple changes.
All we do is add one extra line inside
of our gradient descent for loop,
which once we've computed the gradients
of our of our loss function with respect
to the image,
we just pass that through a neural
network,
uh which has you know, some free
parameters theta,
uh which are just another additional
input to the to the to the hybrid
function.
So yeah, the the four loop looks like
this. Same same thing. All we do is just
add this neural network correction to
the gradient.
Okay.
Yeah.
You have like both of the neural
networks in your workflow. Yeah. Do you
then kind of make it pay attention to
like training one first and then the
other? Yeah. And
hopefully some of the gradients cancel
away. Yeah, I I could good question. So
So what you're suggesting is
maybe we could have a neural network
that does both the forward modeling and
it does the gradient descent step, are
you suggesting? So what do you what do
you think? Do you think How would you
train them?
I would maybe kind of
uh
fit one first on the data. Yeah. And
then like add the other one and fit that
on the data. Yeah.
Yeah, probably for for learning forward
forward modeling, that probably makes
sense. You might want to train that
model first, otherwise
you're not even doing the forward
simulation correctly.
But in general, you have the option to
train both at the same time.
Uh
because you can Well, so I'll show you
how I'm going to talk about that. Then
Uh so now we need to think about how do
we train train this hybrid approach? So
how how do we actually train this neural
network? Uh
So this is a question that we asked
Remember Remember last lecture
uh or even the lecture before, we were
talking about um hybrid forward
simulation. So this solver in the loop
where we had
a neural network we had for it again
that that hybrid algorithm had a for
loop and we had a neural network in that
for loop.
Um So how do how do we train
this this approach? How do we learn
theta?
If you just think back to how we did it
previously.
Can anyone tell me?
What loss function would we use? What
inputs outputs would we use?
Okay, so I'll tell you. It's not
immediately obvious. Um
So, what we should do is what we can do
is
think about the inputs and the outputs
of this function. So, remember this is
just
This is just a function at the end of
the day
that has some inputs and some outputs
and and we just want to learn some of
the inputs of the function. This is what
I was trying to tell you with auto
differentiation and differentiating
through scientific programs.
So, let's just think about the kind of
the inputs to that function and the
outputs of that function. And that's
going to help us define a loss function
to train this this neural network.
So, you know, I've just plotted the the
inputs of this function here. We just
start with an image, a guess of what the
image is
and our observational data.
We run this complicated for loop with
gradient descent and and a neural
network inside.
But, eventually the final output of this
function is just simply our guess at
what the the final image is, the
solution of the inverse problem.
So, now that I've told you what the
inputs and outputs are, can anyone think
of a a loss function that we might might
use now
to train this?
How we what we going to match
the output of the algorithm to?
Yeah.
Exactly. Yeah, it's very simple. We just
Our desired goal is to have this
algorithm converge on the solution.
So, we should just match the output We
should have a loss function which
matches the output of of the hybrid
solver to the to the ground truth image.
So, it's as simple as that. Like
um
we just say
Here's our loss function. We just say
So, H here is just the the whole hybrid
function
uh which takes in you know our guess of
the image, our observational data, and
the parameters of the network.
And we just match this whole output of
this function to to
a ground a set of ground truth images.
So, A here, we assume that we have some
ground truth images or many examples of
ground truth images that we can that we
can do this to.
Does that make sense to everyone?
So, our training data is basically many
thousands of examples of of true images
and uh some observational data based on
these images and and some starting
guess, basically.
Which we can we can generate.
And uh
now you should realize that we can just
differentiate through this whole thing
to get the gradient of the loss with
respect to the parameters.
Because as I was saying, these
scientific programs, we can just think
of them as as uh vector functions, and
we can use auto diff to just get
gradients of the output of that vector
function with respect to the the the the
the weights of the neural network.
So, yeah, we're just doing a very simple
uh
outer training gradient descent loop
here where we're running gradient
descent on gradient descent to train the
network. So, this is where it kind of
gets a bit spicy or a bit exotic as
we're doing kind of
uh learning to learn. We're like
learning an optimizer to kind of learn
the inverse problem.
Uh
So, this for loop here, uh you start
with some initial guess of what theta
is.
You run it through the hybrid uh solver.
You get you compute your loss function,
then you just use auto grad to get the
gradient of of the of the
of this loss function with respect to
the the weights of the neural network.
So, what we call this is like yeah, we
call it gradient descent on gradient
descent or like learning to learn or uh
this is also known as meta-learning,
depending on on what field you want to
you want to talk about this.
Um any questions on on this so far?
Okay.
Um, and so this paper from Adler is a
really good paper and it basically
proposes this technique where we try and
learn the update step
CT imaging.
And this I mean this is long story short
this is the kind of example of learned
learned gradient descent with this
learned update versus just a traditional
version of gradient descent.
And what you see is that the learned
learned solver once we've trained this
neural network to to update the
gradients and step in a in a better
direction.
Does seem to learn like a smoother and
and more accurate solution to the to the
inverse problem.
Um,
so
we
we don't just have to stop there. We can
actually carry on and and so what we
just had a discussion on was
well, why not just add more learnable
components to this to this workflow. We
don't just have to learn the update
step. Maybe we can learn other parts as
well that we're not kind of sure of or
that we want to speed up.
So
yeah, we already kind of had this
discussion another place that we could
add it for example is in this
forward modeling step.
So I've this is the forward modeling
here in this case it's just a numerical
integration to to get the
the line integral of the rays.
But we could maybe replace that if that
was expensive with a with a approximate
neural network for example.
The example that I've got here is
actually a different idea and it's the
to learn kind of the the
lambda hyper parameter of the of the
inverse
objective function. So
So this remember our objective function
in the inverse problem is to say
what's the difference between our
estimated
observed data and our true observed
data.
Um and then we add this regularization
term to try and guide the search towards
like a a reasonable image.
Uh and we have to choose some kind of uh
waiting of these two different loss
terms, but and that's a hyper parameter
that we would typically scan across to
um
uh to to kind of tune it to to work the
best.
But we could try and learn this uh in
the same way. Uh we just treat that as a
as a learnable parameter.
So this is this is uh two different
ideas for for learning for learning this
workflow.
So this is kind of the key idea that I
want you to take away from this kind of
advanced example of a hybrid workflow is
is that we're not limited to just re-
replacing one part of the workflow with
a with a learnable component. We can put
learnable components throughout the
workflow and we're kind of choose free
to choose where we want to to learn
those those parts.
So it would probably be a bad idea to
replace everything. Then you would just
have a really ill-defined algorithm.
Uh so this is where your kind of common
sense as a scientist comes in. You have
to really understand your traditional
algorithm and know the reasonable places
where you actually want to learn the
component and whether that still makes a
reasonable algorithm as as output.
Um
So yeah, in in in summary that these are
all all the kind of ideas that I have I
I I have of putting learnable components
into this into this workflow. So
you could put it at every single step.
You could have, for example,
um
a neural network here which gives us a
better starting model. So it turns out
the starting model is crucial for these
inverse problems to solve. If we don't
start with a a good approximation of the
solution, they often don't converge at
all.
So we could have a neural network which
takes the observational data and just
produces a initial guess of what the the
model is. This could This could already
solve the problem depending on how how
easy the inverse problem is.
Then we could, as you suggested, have a
forward model which we learn, which is
much faster.
We could We have this update step that
we're learning to try and
navigate the search space or the loss
function better.
We could learn a regularizer instead of
just the lambda hyperparameter to add
the regularizer.
We could actually learn like a function
that takes takes the image and tells you
if it's a good image or not.
Who's heard of discriminator networks or
or generative adversarial networks?
Hands up.
Yeah.
So, what's a discriminator network? Does
anyone know?
What it What's the input and output of a
discriminator?
So, what a discrim- Yeah, go on. You got
it. I think it gets real and fake
images. Yeah.
Yeah, basically Yeah, so a discriminator
net when we're using when we apply it to
image generation, it takes in an image
and tries to tell you if that image is
fake or if it's true.
So, we could use like a discriminant
type network here where we could have a
the network takes the image and tells us
is that a good solution to the inverse
problem or is it a fake image? Is it not
a good solution?
So, people have done this as well,
trained trained like discriminator
regularizers inside their algorithms.
And then, what's brilliant and
about hybrid workflows and it is that we
can just
learn this so-called end-to-end, right?
So, we take the outputs of the entire
algorithm and we match it to our desired
output. So, we
we optimize what we care about, which is
the final image if that's output by the
algorithm.
And this is where the power of autograd
comes in. Autograd just lets us get
these gradients of the loss
differentiating through this whole kind
of hybrid workflow to to get our
gradients.
Um
Any Any more questions on on this?
Otherwise, I'll move on. Yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, okay. I think you've got the answer
there. You You just said it. Yeah.
So, good question. So, the question was
uh
if this network takes the observation
observation data and tries to guess what
the image is, why do we even need this
algorithm?
Well, the answer is So, people have done
that as well for sure. Uh and it can
work. It's just But, if your inverse
problem is very ill-posed, so there's a
many there's a one-to-many relationship
between the observational data and the
possible solutions,
then this will pull out uh maybe just
one of those solutions.
Or more likely, if you use like a simple
loss function, it will actually give you
like the average solution,
which is not actually desirable. If you
you might get a very smooth average kind
of type of image.
Uh
So,
uh there are ways around that. Um but,
yeah, this is
What I'm trying to suggest here is
that is a good first step, but then we
can build on it and learn uh solver
around that to improve it even further.
Yeah.
I don't uh Yeah, so So, for CT imaging,
uh
yeah, there's no ground truth available
perhaps. But, what we could do and what
we usually do is just do a very
high-resolution image inexpensive uh to
get create an expensive training data
set.
So, there are for example CT scanners in
like research labs that are like super
high-resolution that have many many rays
and many many angles to give us a really
high-resolution image. So, we can use
use that as ground truth to then solve a
problem that has maybe less
observational data. But, yeah, I mean,
it's a limitation for sure. Yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah. yeah. Is that also something
that is something Yeah. Right. Right.
So, I mean,
a more mathematically like kind of
rigorous way to frame inverse problems
is to
frame it in a Bayesian inference setting
where you're trying to invert for the
posterior distribution. That's what you
really want to do because we know that
it's like a one-to-many relationship.
So,
there are for sure hybrid methods that
go that you can insert into Bayesian
inference and maybe using a VAE or
something like this to approximate some
of those distributions is is the way,
but I don't have the time to go into it.
We can talk about it later if you Yeah.
Yeah.
Um
Yeah, for example, uh there's this kind
of neat thing in um uh
gradient descent when you're training
neural networks is when the optimizer is
bumping around the kind of local minima,
you can think of that as something in
the posterior distribution.
So, you can kind of use that kind of
concept to it sometimes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Right. So,
what I'm doing here is just summarizing
hybrid hybrid techniques before we move
on to the next lecture, which is going
to discuss something related but not
quite the same.
So,
the key takeaway is that these
traditional scientific algorithms, we
can make them as learnable
like flexible or as unlearnable as as we
like, and
this comes down to our kind of as a
scientist, we have to make that that
decision on what parts of the workflow
we think we can improve.
Um
And yeah, inside hybrid inverse
algorithms, neural networks can be very
effective at learning priors, uh so to
help us converge on a solution when the
problem is ill-posed, and also improving
efficiency. It can replace the kind of
the slow parts of the algorithm.